تجري تركي انتخابات قد تحدد مصيره حزب
العداله والتنميه الحاكم منذ العام 2003
وبالتالي مصير الرئيس نفسه رجب طيب
اردوغان الانتخابات ستشمل الرئاسه
والبرلمان وحددت في الثامن عشر من يونيو
20 23 لكن الرئيس التركي لما حائل انها قد
تجرى بوقت ابكر قليلا مراعاه للظروف
الموسميه بحسب ما قاله اردوغان اليوم
التحدي الاكبر الذي تواجهه البلاد يتمثل
بالاقتصاد انهارت قيمه الليره بشكل متكرر
امام الدولار لتستقر حاليا عند ثمانيه عشر
او عند 18 ليره فاصل 74 مقابل الدولار
واحد وسباقا للانتخابات المهمه اعلن
الرئيس التركي اجراء تعديل على زياده
رواتب الموظفين الحكوميين والمتقاعدين
لتصبح 30 بالمئه بدلا من 25 بحسب ما
اوردته وكاله انباء الاناضول الرسميه
لترتفع اجور متقاعدينا مثلا من ثلاثه
الاف,500 ليره الى
5,500 ليره اعتبارا من الشهر الجاري
تعلمونا جميعا اهميه الانتخابات خليه يتم
تحديث موعدها ليكون ابكر قليلا في هذا
العام لمراعاه بعض الظروف الموسميه
المتعلقه بالمناخ والاجواء
ومع اقتراب التصويت المصيريه نجد خمس
قضايا تنتظر الحسن في تركيا
وتوصف ضمن مده زمنيه قصيره لا تتعدى
الاربعه اشهر اولها والاكبر هي من ينافس
الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان لم تتمكن احزاب
المعارضه من الاتفاق على اسم معين حتى
الان امر يصب بمصلحه الرئيس القضيه
الساخنه الثانيه هي القضايا المرفوعه ضد
المنافس المحتمل رئيس بلديه اسطنبول
الاكرم امام بلو الذي حكم بالسجن اكثر من
عامين في قضيه تعود جذورها لتاريخ تسلمه
كرسي البلديه كما يواجه امام اوغلو قضيه
اخرى وهي ادعاء من مفتشيه وزاره الداخليه
رفعوه للنيابه بشان الادعاء بان الرجل وظف
اشخاصا مرتبطين بالارهاب في البلديه
القضيه او المعضله الثالثه الخطيره انجاز
التعبير تتمثل بترقب الاوساط التركيه قضيه
تتعلق بحل حزب الشعوب الديمقراطيه المتهم
بوجود صلات له مع حزب العمال الكردستاني
المصنف ارهابيا في تركيا والاتحاد
الاوروبي والولايات المتحده تمهيدا لقرار
الحل ربما قررت المحكمه الدستوريه العليا
اليوم حرمان الحزب مؤقتا من المخصصات
الماليه البالغه
539 مليون ليره تركيه اي ما يقارب 29
مليون دولار وذكرت محطه ام تي في في
الخاصه التركيه ان قرار حرمان حزب الشعوب
الديمقراطي من المخصصات الماليه اعتمد
بغالبيه ثمانيه اصوات مؤيده ومعارضه سبعه
ونتابع اذا ذكرت ذلك محطه ان تي في الخاصه
القضيه الرابعه المهمه هي قضيه التعديلات
الدستوريه التي طرح رئيس حزب الشعب
الجمهوريه كمال كليتش دار اوغلو ومنها
العوده للنظام البرلماني لكنه اقتراح لم
يمرر طالما بقيا حزب العداله والتنميه
صاحب الاغلبيه في البرلمان اضافه الى
تعديلات اخرى
وتتطلب الموافقه على اجراء تعديل في
الدستور في البرلمان التركي الحصول على
400 صوت واذا ترووحت الاصوات ما بين 360
و400 صوت فانه يمكن نقل او يمكن له ان
يطرح على الاستفتاء الشعبي
[موسيقى]
سياسي
التحدي الاخير داخلي وخارجي على اعتبار ان
القضيه الخامسه ترتبط بجزء اكبر بالسياسه
الخارجيه لتركيا التي شهدت تحولا كبيرا
خلال العام الماضي الا انها تتعلق ايضا
بمحددات داخليه من جهه اخرى كالتطبيعه مع
النظام السوري الذي تحدث اردوغان بخصوصه
عن امكانيه اللقاء بالاسد قريبا بواسطه
الروسيه وبعدما تقدم لا يعرف حتى الان من
سيكون له الحظ الاكبر للفوز في انتخابات
الرئاسه في البلاد خصوصا مع التضارب نتائج
استطلاعات الراي التي يرى مراقبون انها لا
تعبر عن نتائج حاسمه في ما يتوقع البعض ان
تحسم الانتخابات من الجوله الاولى بينما
يرى اخرون ان هذا الامر مستعد وانها ستشهد
جولتين يجب ان يحصل المرشحون على نسبه 50
زائد واحد من الاصوات على الاقل بالمئه
طبعا ليتم انتخابهم لكن وفي حال لم يحصل
اي مرشح على الاغلبيه المطلقه في الجوله
الاولى ستجرى جوله ثانيه بعد 15 يوما بين
المرشحين الذين حصلوا على اكبر عدد من
الاصوات اولا وبعد ذلك سينتخب المرشح الذي
يحصل على اغلبيه الاصوات الصحيحه رئيسا
لتركيا